hello and welcome to another Python
tutorial in this tutorial we're gonna be
talking about how to manipulate actual
files so how do we delete rename and
move files and even directories so with
that let's get into it let's make a fake
directory here and we'll just call this
whole folder and within home folder
we're gonna make just some random stuff
another folder and then we're gonna have
a let's do an image and then we'll just
make an extra text document here okay
so now we have stuff within this whole
folder so the next thing we want to do
is delete stuff like let's delete
something from that folder so the first
things that we're going to need or gonna
have to import to font or to imports and
the first one is going to be glob for
global and then import OS now the next
thing we want to do is specify the
directory that this stuff is located in
now you can shorten the directories for
example we're file delete you can just
save old folder right so we could say
whole folder oh my goodness and type and
then use /i think equals back slashes as
long as you use two I want to say but
just use a forward slash it makes
navigating a lot easier so then within
whole folder let's say we want to go
ahead and delete this text document so
let me just make a copy of it and we're
going to leave this one so so we'll say
that's our directory whole folder now
the next thing we want to do is say Oh
SCH Durr we want to change directory
into that directory subsequently we want
to specify the files that we want to
delete so that'll be global side whoa
and then anything
directory ending with txt it's getting
the axe for filename in files we want to
do OS on link filename unlike your short
for dominated so let's go ahead and run
this pop this over here and we see it
actually deleted both of our text
documents because we said to delete
everything that was text but everything
else is still intact so we end elite
everything just the text files so now I
know you know what everybody wants to
know is how do we delete the entire
directory you know do some serious
destruction so if you might be thinking
you could just maybe delete all from a
whole folder but if you do that let me
show you what ends up happening you get
access denied we don't have access to do
that because this isn't like a ballad
windows program I think you could go
into your user account settings and just
take away the requirement for access so
it's kind of like whenever you download
like a third party program and you go to
run it and windows is like are you sure
you know that's not happening here
instead we're just trying to go ahead
and go through it and not ask for access
and it's getting denied so you could go
through and remove that or you could
actually delete whole directories this
way so I'm going to show you guys the
way to delete directories properly
without making yourself super vulnerable
plus it's going to take a lot less code
now when you do this before we kind of
use short-handed we just said okay the
folder because this is our file was
mellow kated right here but let's let's
use it we're going to use a different
function and we're going to type out the
entire thing just due to the nature of
this function here so we're gonna import
SH util and from Shu till we want to get
the remove tree so this is going to
remove though entire tree so the tree
that we want to remove we're gonna give
the entire location because it's going
to remove a tree
you're not really I mean you're kind of
specifying the name but it's just good
to go ahead and type out the entire
thing whenever you're deleting files
especially whole folders really so this
is gonna users aged desktop and we're
hiding over here in syntax
lessons in the file manip folder and we
want to go ahead and delete the entire
whole folder and that's it it's a one
line function basically so you hit it
you go goodbye a whole folder it is now
gone so that's pretty much it with
deleting directories and files in the
next tutorial I'm gonna be showing you
guys how to rename into move files so
kind of like deleting and well deleting
it besides from the directory it was
kind of different functions but deleting
is pretty much the same overall and then
also renaming and moving it's kind of
the same thing so with that hopefully
that's helping some of you guys stay
tuned to the next video as always thanks
for watching